from Kim's uncertain future to the fate
of various Breaking Bad characters
here's what we're still wondering about
after the final season of Better Call
Saul of all the places why did the
wealthy criminal lawyers escape to the
cold and unforgiving land of Omaha
Nebraska was it just an obscure location
to avoid being captured after all it
almost was as Gene does go unnoticed for
a matter of time before former
Albuquerque cab driver Jeff recognizes
him however this location is actually
both a reference to a throwaway line
from Breaking Bad and an important place
from Kim wechsler's past Saul tells Walt
as they hide out under the vacuum repair
shop in the Breaking Bad episode granted
State a prediction of his future I'm
lucky month from now best case scenario
I'm managing a Cinnabon in Omaha this
scene is Revisited in the series finale
of Better Call Saul and also serves as a
setup for the prequel series The sad
fulfillment of this line is accompanied
by a gorgeous black and white
composition that captures The Emptiness
of the icing slinging Gene takovic
however that may not be the the only
reason Saul hides out there as we learn
in season 6 from Kim's flashback earring
thievery she's actually from Omaha as
seen on her mother's license plate was
Saul originally hoping Kim may have
returned here and chosen Nebraska in
hopes of a reunion before we Flash
Forward to full saw we witnessed the
devastating breakup of Jimmy and Kim
once again the exact timeline is a
little unclear it's hard to pinpoint
just how long it's been since Kim made
that difficult decision due to The
Artful way in which the series portrays
the passage of time so the question is
how long was Jimmy left alone before he
received a fat check from a case he
first discovered in season one it would
be interesting to know how long Jimmy
was forced to sit with himself before
Saul crept up and fully took over his
Persona and life who gave him the call
updating him on the case now that Hamlin
Hamlin and McGill is fully dissolved was
it a reluctant conversation with the
Davis and Maine representative or could
it have possibly been Aaron Brill his
old co-worker who kept a close eye on
Jimmy during his time there Manuel Varga
Nacho's father played a pivotal role in
his son's final episodes the automobile
upholstery shop owner and upstanding
citizen was the epitome of good in a
series full of morally gray characters
and others who have intentionally broken
bed thankfully nacho was able to share a
tear-jerking goodbye with his father
before he met his untimely demise
however the question remains what was
the fate of Manuel the last we saw of
Nacho's father Mike paid him a visit to
let him know that his son died a good
man thematically Mike gave Manuel a
sense of closure Mike will never have
while providing viewers with another
redeeming moment for the ex-officer and
further revealing his honorable true
nature while we may never see Manuel
again thanks to Mike he will at least
have some sense of closure as he
presumably continues to work in his shop
hopefully without nacho around Manuel
will be safe from the cartel as he can
no longer be used as leverage if you are
true to your word
there will be no reason for anyone to
harm your father
there were very few joyful moments in
the Grimm series finale however however
Kim wechsler remains one of the show's
most hopeful characters who still seems
worthy of true redemption in a strict
exercise of self-discipline Kim settles
for a simple life living in Florida
working at Palm Coast sprinklers where
she creates brochures and catalogs for
the company after her explosive call was
Saul she takes accountability for her
actions by confessing to her part in
Howard's death and volunteering at her
local free legal clinic Kim soon returns
to her true nature by burying herself in
paperwork in an interview with
Entertainment Weekly Rhea seahorn breaks
down this turn of events and what it
might mean for Kim's future saying I
think she's thinking two things one that
it's possible that I can allow myself to
find some joy and passion in my life
again and two that it's possible that I
can atone for my actions in an active
way instead of just a passive way she
expands on Kim's more authentic altruism
and even teases a possible future
reunion with Jimmy all of which is tied
into the cathartic decision to
acknowledge her past mistakes the
double-edged sword with Kim finding
happiness again is there is now someone
out there who wants to snatch it away
after Kim remorsefully unveils her role
in Howard's death she brings her
completed statement to his widow in an
attempt to make amends Cheryl Hamlin is
understandably livid at this Revelation
and threatens to suit him in civil court
for everything she has in the event Kim
avoids prosecution with the overall lack
of evidence or Witnesses available to
implicate Kim and Howard's death it
seems unlikely that she'll be prosecuted
especially after Jimmy clears her name
in the series finale however should
Cheryl learn that Kim has re-entered the
law and is even on speaking terms with
her convicted ex-husband Jimmy the
wronged Widow May seek Vengeance this
could involve taking Kim to civil court
as promised and even exposing her past
to her new Associates in Florida
potentially shattering Kim's fragile
fresh start after Jimmy weaponizes the
law in Saul's signature style he has a
sudden change of heart after seeing Kim
however this ultimately lands him in a
far less luxurious prison than he
originally worked out for himself his
initial sweet deal of seven years is
increased to a crushing sentence of 86
after his astonishing admission of guilt
in which he details his actions in
shielding Heisenberg from prison during
his crime Reign he protects Kim and even
displays remorse for not doing more to
save his brother Chuck and admits the
role he played in the events that led to
his brother's tragic death as star Bob
Odenkirk stated during an interview with
Entertainment Weekly it's the bravest
most honest thing he can do the series
finale sees Jimmy return to using his
birth name while serving his sentence at
the very prison he wanted to avoid adx
Montrose as indicated by the letters on
his jumpsuit however adx Montrose may
not be the final stop for Jimmy as Ria's
seahorn offers a ray of Hope with
Entertainment Weekly that suggests he
could be seeing more of his ex-wife
seahorn explained I think she's going to
go through a very complicated process of
trying to figure out if she can help
decrease his sentence in a way that is
still just and I don't think that's the
last time they'll see each other not by
a long shot the last three episodes of
Better Call Saul intertwine with the
original Series in some interesting ways
in the season 6's third to last episode
aptly titled Breaking Bad Gene catches
up with his old Secretary Francesca
played by Tina Parker she updates him on
the fate of a few of Walt's old
accomplices the first is Walt's Widow
Skyler white who presumably got her deal
with the DEA although she also mentions
that Jesse pinkman's abandoned El Camino
was found somewhere near the border of
Mexico so where are Skyler and her son
Walter Jr now when viewers last saw them
in the Breaking Bad series finale they
were living in a small apartment and
attempting to live quiet lives that
could be the reason why they didn't
accompany Marie to face Jimmy in court
Walter Jr is in for some good news
though as he still has the 9.7 million
dollars coming for his 18th birthday
from Walter's leftover drug money in the
form of an irrevocable trust from Elliot
and crutcher's Company gray matter
Technologies Marie's unexpected
appearance in the finale was an enormous
Delight for both the fans and crew
Better Call Saul co-creator Peter gold
praised actress Betsy brantz returned
during an inner interview with variety
he said I was so grateful that she was
willing to come to Albuquerque she has a
couple of scenes so she was there for
quite a while working with her reminded
me of what a brilliant actress she is
and every time she did her scenes she
would bring something a little different
viewers can also be confident that
underneath all that beautiful black and
white footage used in the final episode
of Better Call Saul Marie was draped in
her signature purple while delivering
one of the best lines of the series
tell me they found you in a garbage
dumpster
while Breaking Bad ended in 2013 most
fans thought we'd Seen the Last of Walt
and Jesse however even then there was
some comfort in knowing that the
Universe would continue with the already
announced prequel spin-off about the
loudmouth criminal lawyer Saul however
now we are facing the possible
conclusion of the entire franchise still
there is a shred of Hope remaining
thanks to some recent comments that
Peter Gould made to The Hollywood
Reporter which suggests that this may
not be the end of the Breaking Bad Saga
Gould said look if Vince or I or any of
the folks who worked on the show had an
idea that we were excited about Never
Say Never Vince and I both feel like we
want and need to do something different
and change things up if we ever did come
back to this universe hopefully we bring
a new set of ideas that would enrich it
and give us something different deadline
recently reported that Vince Gilligan's
next show is going to be an Apple TV
plus series starring Rhea seahorn but
isn't expected to be related to the
stories of Better Call Saul and Breaking
Bad while this is certainly an exciting
New Direction for Gilligan fans are
still hoping for a return to Albuquerque
in the the not too distant future
that makes my life much easier
[Music]